April the 22nd 2015 is the anniversary
of a very sad and unpleasant event in
warfare it is the hundredth anniversary
of the first use of chlorine as a poison
gas in the First World War it was used
by the Germans in an attack on French
troops outside the Belgian city of Ypres
which in the first world war the English
soldiers called wipers because they
couldn't pronounce French so what
happened was that a large amount of
chlorine more than a hundred tons was
released from cylinders and swept across
the battlefield
onto the totally unprepared troops
chlorine gas is very corrosive turns
copper and brass the sort of things that
soldiers have on the metal of their
buckles turns green it attacks the eyes
and it also if it gets in the lungs your
lungs stop filling up with fluid so it's
really unpleasant and it was a huge
success large numbers of people and all
animals died and the whole front was
opened up but the Germans had not
expected it to be a success and didn't
have the troops that we could pull
forward to fill the vacuum night fell
and by the next day the people were back
the French troops were back to defend
the front so it really wasn't much
advantage
this whole chlorine attack was the idea
of Fritz Harbor the famous chemists that
we've all heard of for the harbour
process making ammonia he became really
enthused if not obsessed with chemical
warfare and this obsession led to him
being dubbed a pretty evil genius in his
lifetime and he is still remembered for
role in chemical warfare almost more
than his role in providing fertilizers
that makes all the food that we eat
possible what is surprising is that a
Canadian officer the Canadians were next
to the French realized it was chlorine
remarkably quickly and so primitive
precautions were taken pretty quickly
nothing very sophisticated people
urinating onto their handkerchiefs to
cover their faces so the water will
absorb some of the chlorine I don't
think it is a very effective so I would
not suggest that you try this if there
is a chlorine release the important
thing is that this opened up a whole era
of chemical warfare and within a few
weeks if not months both sides were
firing chemicals at the others their two
important points that we need to
remember the first thing is that
chlorine this greeny yellow gas is
really quite an unpleasant material Neal
our really tough technician is quite
frightened of it many years ago he was
exposed to a small amount of chlorine
gas and he still remembers that was long
before periodic videos and all the
safety precautions we now take but the
second point is that people are still
using chlorine as a chemical weapon in
yesterday's newspaper there was a story
that said that in Syria barrel bombs of
chlorine are still being used so I think
it is important to remind you that
although chemistry is a fascinating and
exciting subject it can be misused and
it is our duty as chemists to make sure
that chemistry is used for the benefit
of society not for its destruction
in the First World War better chemical
weapons than chlorine particularly
mustard gas which is a compound of
carbon hydrogen sulfur and chlorine was
invented which lasted on the
battlefields for months and in the
Second World War and afterwards
so-called nerve gases were just a few
milligrams of the compound can kill
somebody
so using chlorine is a pretty primitive
weapon but when you are an armed force
fighting against civilians who have no
protection chlorine is a cheap and
pretty reliable way of making things
very uncomfortable if not actually
killing people and chlorine is available
industrially very easily whereas
chemical weapons are more difficult to
get hold of